we're here at the desk with the legend
the icon the one and only Martha Stewart
now
who here is single may I ask
fantastic single audience
um who here is married
oh a nice like 50 50 split now I happen
to be single for seven years I'm single
for like 30 years okay now I'm not I'm
not proud of it
why do you think that is because I was
stupid
do you think that also you might be I
should have married along the way in the
dating in the dating time after I got
divorced I did date a lot
you had fun oh yeah I had a lot of fun
but I didn't take it as a priority is it
a priority now no but it should have
been because you know I just I think I
miss it
you miss companionship no I'm not gonna
cry about that
um I don't know if I missed a
companionship so much as the just the
fun it's fun to date well
let's get you on a date well I don't
have to really go on a date I have so I
I'm very busy see I use that as my
excuse
yes I understand but there are moments
there are seasons there are minutes
where I go
it would be nice yeah that's what I say
then I see some people's relationships
and I'm like oh my God thank God I'm
single
you know so it's a little bit of both
but what I love on this show is talking
about all the new dating terms we're
living in an era where we've never lived
before this is unprecedented with
technology what dating apps so let's do
some red yellow and green stand for it's
a go it's good I say Yes red is a no now
a no no no no and yellow is like I'm on
the fence oh okay
okay so I'll read a detail about a
hypothetical date here we go your date
has as many tattoos as Pete Davidson
green flag red flag yellow flag
I knew it Martha unique I knew it could
have bet money in Vegas on that one okay
your date is Pete Davidson
I knew it there's a thing on the
internet where everybody wants you to go
on a date with it dated so many women so
what no I'm not saying it that's bad I
think that's good and he's sort of cute
everybody loves them I I know everybody
loves them I know him oh oh you didn't
know I know him I mean I do know that's
probably why he was on the beaver roast
with me do you remember yes he was this
little twerp of The Beatles
he was even trippier than Bieber
well I I got it it was also very cute by
the way oh he's so handsome oh he's cute
and lovely I met him and Haley just
seemed so lovely yes but everybody
speaks about Pete Davidson in such a
positive way like he has to be a good
guy oh he's a good guy he's a very good
guy and he knows he knows how to get in
and get out
well
green
to you know age is not a thing for him
saying
he's like he's like my lost son
well maybe he has you know I don't know
okay what else okay
your date used a photo from 10 years ago
on their dating profile green flag
yellow flag red flag
yellow okay oh that's interesting they
might not have a recent photo
who doesn't have a recent photo
some people tootin common
thank you for getting that joke there's
a generation
okay your date wants to cook for you on
their first date
[Applause]
[Music]
actually it could also be red
because you won't know in time to finish
products I might maybe they're too cheap
to take me out
[Laughter]
well if they're
for you and it's
and it's hey it's not great
I knew that was going to be your
response bye I knew it bye if you cook
like this forget it
there's room to learn and I can't think
of it I teach not going to teach a
boyfriend
[Applause]
you know what I'm saying with the like
pottery and some Unchained Melody nope
all right your date tries to play
footsie with you under the table that's
nice foreign
[Applause]
by the way I was gonna say the audience
response felt like a real tepid yellow
flag I love when your guys's cacophony
chimes in I'm really and you're weirdly
really in unison
okay your date talks about sex on the
first date
and you should have just seen my face
there I was like
your date doesn't like to share food
it depends
I'm with you guys
like really you want a french kiss me
but not give me a bite of your dish
it's weird
um your date tries to take a selfie with
you
that's okay okay good all right
you can't cook you're out but photograph
away your date burps
uh but says excuse me
you know disgusting okay and last one
your date doesn't like Snoop Dogg
it doesn't like Snoop Dogg maybe I mean
I'm open to opinion
I love Snoop Dogg is he as cool as we
all want him to be as cool even more
cool really yes oh that makes me so
happy yes well I gotta say this has been
the highlight of my year thank you so
much for playing Grandpa green flag
yellow flags
on the Roku Channel now that gets all my
Flags except for that one
not even that one that's what Martha
gets
[Music]